[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis guten Abend und willkommen für
den Sport ist Norbert Lehmann im Studio
einen schön guten Abend Tag von mir das
sind die großen Themen
heute Missbrauch in der evangelischen
Kirche eine Studie zeigt das Ausmaß
sexualisierte Gewalt ist viel größer als
bislang
bekannt gefährlicher Erdrutsch Dänemark
droht eine Umweltkatastrophe weil ein
gigantischer giftmüllberg in Bewegung
gerät und träumen vom Titel nach der
Klatsche gegen Kroatien hofft das
dhbteam im em Halbfinale gegen den
Weltmeister auf ein kleines
Wunder es ist noch viel mehr Kindern und
Jugendlichen in der evangelischen Kirche
undter Diakone sexualisierte Gewalt
angetan worden als bisher bekannt war
das belegt ein eine heute vorgestellte
Studie das Ausmaß ist offenbar ähnlich
groß wie in der katholischen Kirche
bisher war bekannt dass seit 1946
innerhalb der evangelischen Kirche
858 Kinder und Jugendliche Opfer
sexualisierter Gewalt wurden die Studie
jetzt spricht von mindestens
2225 Opfern tatsächlich sei die Zahl
aber wohl noch weitaus höher als
mutmaßliche Täter wurden mindestens
1259 K Beschäftigte erfasst auch hier
gebe es eine hohe Dunkelziffer Oliver
deuker
berichtet als Minderjährige wurde die
heute 50-Jährige Katharina kracht vom
Pastor ihrer Kirchengemeinde missbraucht
über viele Jahre hinweg kein Einzelfall
in der evangelischen Kirche wie die fast
900 Seiten umfassende unabhängige Studie
zeigt ich halte die Studie für
ausgesprochen wichtig weil sie nämlich
endlich das mal wissenschaftlich belegt
was wir seit so vielen Jahren sagen die
evangelische Kirche hat ein Problem mit
sexualisierter Gewalt es finden sich
auch hier hohe Zahlen und sie hat vor
allem auch ein Problem damit wie sie mit
den Betroffenen umgeht wenn Sie sich
melden Kritik die Missbrauchsopfer seit
Jahren benennen die aber von
Verantwortlichen der evangelischen
Kirche häufig heruntergespielt wurde
heute nicht wir übernehmen als
Institution Verantwortung für die
Gewalttaten die von pahrern
Mitarbeitenden und ehrenamtlichen
unserer Institution begangen
worden dazu gehört es als allererstes zu
sagen wir haben uns auch als Institution
an unzähig vielen Menschen schuldig
gemacht und ich kann sie die sie so
verletzt wurden nur von ganzem Herzen um
Entschuldigung bitten
1259 Beschuldigte und
2225 Opfer konnte die Studie bisher
benennen doch es werden mehr sein denn
es fehlt an Datenmaterial aus den 20
Landeskirchen kritisieren auch die
Studien ma
aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Datenlage
lassen sich hier keine seriösen
Vergleiche ziehen aber es ist die Spitze
der Spitze des Eisbergs die
studienveröffentlichung ein
rabenschwarzer Tag für die evangelische
Kirche es zeigt sich ganz deutlich dass
in evangelischen Kirche ähnlich wie in
der katholischen Kirche es ein großes
Ausmaß an risikoräumen gibt wo
Machtunterschiede und
vertrauensabhängigkeitsverhältnisse von
Tätern genutzt werden um Taten
anzubahnen und sie dann eben auch zu
verüben 3,6 Millionen Euro kostete die
Studie es ist zumindest ein Anfang der
Aufarbeitung sexualisierte Gewalt in der
evangelischen Kirche weitere Fakten aus
der Studie und Reaktionen haben wir
online in der ZDF heute App dort
erfahren sie außer den an wen sich
Betroffene jederzeit wenden
können die Idee eines ringtausches zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine mit
Marschflugkörpern stößt in den Reihen
von FDP GRÜNEN und CDU auf Skepsis dabei
geht es nach Medienberichten um
Vorschläge aus Großbritannien wonach die
Bundeswehr Taurus Marschflugkörper an
Großbritannien oder Frankreich liefern
soll die beiden Länder könnten dann im
Gegenzug ähnliche Waffensysteme an die
Ukraine weitergeben die fdppitikerin
strackzimmermann bekräftigte ihren
Vorschlag das taurussystem sofort an die
Ukraine abzugeben es sei deutlich besser
als die Waffensysteme der
Verbündeten
noch sind viele Fragen offen nach dem
Absturz der russischen Militärmaschine
gestern Moskau wirft Kier vor das
Flugzeug abgeschossen zu haben an Bord
seien auch 65 ukrainische
Kriegsgefangene gewesen die Ukraine
fordert nun eine internationale
Untersuchung die Maschine vom Typ
Ilyushin il76 war nahe der grenznahen
Großstadt bielgorot unterwegs und
stürzte beim Ort jablobonov ab Sebastian
eben berechte
das russische Staatsfernsehen sendet
heute einen
Gedenkgottesdienst Trauer bei den
Angehörigen der Besatzung der
abgeschossenen ilyusi die Botschaft
Russland wurde Opfer eines barbarischen
ukrainischen Angriffs der Vorwurf Kiev
habe das Flugzeug vorsätzlich
abgeschossen obwohl man gewusst habe
dass an Bord ukrainische Kriegsgefangene
waren die ukrainische Seite wurde
offiziell gewarnt ich betone das
offiziell gewnt 15 Minuten bevor das
Flugzeug in die Zone
flog die Ukraine dementiert dass auch
die Menschen in Kiev Glauben der
russischen Erzählung nicht dort ist die
Skepsis und die Wut auf die Russen
groß ich kenne die Russen und glaube
denen kein
Wort wenn wir unsere Gefangenen
verlieren dann ist es natürlich eine
Tragödie klar für die Ukraine für jede
Familie die ein Mitglied verloren hat
ist es eine
Tragödie
die offiziellen ukrainischen Stellen
widersprechen Moskaus Version man habe
bisher keine Informationen darüber dass
sich an Bord ukrainische Gefangene
befunden hätten dass das Flugzeug
abgeschossen wurde dementiert man jedoch
nicht Kiev fordert nun eine
internationale Untersuchung es ist
offensichtlich dass die Russen mit dem
Leben der ukrainischen Gefangenen den
Gefühlen ihrer Angehörigen und den
Emotionen unserer Gesellschaft spielen
es müssen jetzt alle Fakten auf den
Tisch Vladimir Putin äußerte sich heute
in kaliniengrad nicht zum Absturz in
bielgorot dass er eine internationale
Untersuchung auf russischenem Boden
zulässt gilt aber als
ausgeschlossen in Deutschland leben so
viele Menschen wie noch nie so schätzt
es das Statistische Bundesamt ein die
Bevölkerung ist zum Ende des letzten
Jahres auf 84,7 Millionen gestiegen das
ist ein Plus von gut 300.000 im
Vergleich zum vergangenen Jahr und der
bislang höchste Gesamtwert seit der
Wiedervereinigung Grund für diesen
Rekord die Zuwanderung geschätzt seinen
bis zu 71 000 Menschen nach Deutschland
gekommen schauen wir auf den
Arbeitskampf der Lockführer und
lockführerin es ist der zweite Streiktag
die meisten Züge stehen still nur etwa
20% fahren laut
Notfahrplan die wirtschaftlichen Folgen
spüren viele Unternehmen bis hin zu den
bahnhofsgeschäften aber bisher gibt es
zwischen der deutschen Bahn und der GDL
keine Annäherung mehr von julja
Schröter Protestzug der
lockführergewerkschaft in Stuttgart nur
eine von vielen Aktionen im ganzen
Bundesgebiet auch der Vorsitzende der
GDL ist dabei und verteidigt den Streik
gegen Kritik es ist auss Sicht unserer
Kunden sowohl im Güterverkehr als auch
im Personenverkehr nie eine gute Zeit
für ein Streik wir verstehen das aber
wir treten nicht an um zu streigen
sondern wir treten an damit dieses
Eisenbahnsystem gesündet und die
Menschen die dort arbeiten lange
dauerhaft gesund bleiben und vor allen
Dingen wieder Spaß am Beruf haben Streik
Tag 2 und eine Rückkehr an den
Verhandlungstisch für die GDL ist das im
Moment keine Option besonders für
diejenigen die vom Bahnhof Leben ist das
ein großes Problem etwa für Janet
sincher sie ist mit ihrem Blumenladen im
Mainzer Hauptbahnhof fast vollständig
abhängig von Laufkundschaft und die
kommt nun kaum
sehr wenig also der Umsatz geht fast 90%
runter also das heißt wir wenn das so
wenig ist dann müssen wir die Kosten von
eene Tasche bezahlen müssen das ist
nicht schön für die Streikenden hat sie
grundsätzlich Verständnis aber sie müsse
den Streik mitbezahlen ähnlich schlecht
läuft es in diesem Fastfood Laden im
Bahnhof in Hamburg statt Abfertigung der
Kunden im Minutentakt sind sie jetzt
froh über jede Portion Pommes die über
den Tresen geht für die Betreiber ist
der kundenmangel
schmerzhaft muss eingekauft werden die
Miete muss bezahlt werden Strom etc dann
gibt's ja auch noch Abgaben an den
Hauptbahnhof da muss man das Personal
auch noch
bezahlen und mit so welchen Tagen tut
das den Unternehmen natürlich weh sech
Tage Bahnstreik eine Herausforderung für
viele Menschen längst nicht nur für die
Bahnfahrer antisemitische Straftaten
haben in Deutschland dramatisch
zugenommen
2249 Taten hat das Bundeskriminalamt
erfasst zwischen dem S oktober also dem
Tag des terrorüberfalls der Hamas auf
Israel und dem 22 Januar dieses Jahres
aus Sorge vor Angriffen und anfeinungen
bemühten sich jüdische Menschen in
Deutschland seit einigen Monaten in der
Öffentlichkeit weniger aufzufallen
berichtet der Präsident des Zentralrats
der Juden Josef
Schuster in Thüringen ist die
rechtsextreme AFD besonders stark Anfang
September wird dort ein neuer Landtag
gewählt und jetzt haben sich mehr als
3000 Organisationen und Privatpersonen
zu einem Bündnis zusammengetan
weltoffenes Thüringen es ruft dazu auf
Haltung gegen die extreme Rechte zu
zeigen heute ist ihre Kampagne gestartet
mit dabei auch viele Unternehmen Daniela
Sonntag und Melanie ha
berichten so viele und so viele
verschiedene Akteure in einem
zivilbündnis das gab es bislang nicht im
Freistaat Verbände Firmen Kirchen
Privatpersonen Haltung zeigen für ein
weltoffenes Thüringen seit Monaten
vorbereitet auch von Erik wrasse
Thüringen wird wirklich wahrgenommen mit
diesen 30 35% für eine rechtsextreme
Partei und wir wollen zeigen Thüringen
ist sehr viel mehr Thüringen ist jetzt
schon vielfältig weltoffen die in
Thüringen als rechtsextrem eingestufte
AFD um börn höcke liegt in Umfragen mit
Abstand vor das sehen auch in der
Wirtschaft viele mit Sorge unter den
mehr als 3000 Unterstützern des
Bündnisses viele Industrieunternehmen
wie der Jenoptik Konzern mithalten beim
Wettbewerb der Arbeitgeber beim Kampf um
die besten Köpfe da spiele das Image des
Wirtschaftsstandortes eine große
Rolle wir sind ja ein Unternehmen das
aus Jena aus Thüringen kommt aber
international tätig ist mit 4in000
Mitarbeitern davon 1700 hier in
Thüringen aus mehr als 30 Nationen und
das allein glaube ich beschreibt schon
wie wichtig es für uns ist ein offenes
willkommensklima zu
haben anziehen und halten auch in
anderen Branchen spüren Sie die
Auswirkungen des politischen Klimas um
eine gute Betreuung Bildung Pflege
aufrecht zu halten sind wir natürlich
auf Menschen Fachkräfte Arbeitskräfte
angewiesen die in unserem schönen
Thüringen tätig werden wollen ob Sie aus
Deutschland kommen oder aus dem Ausland
und wir hören dort Stimmen die sich
Sorgen machen kann ich in Zukunft in
Thüringen noch gut leben lauter werden
präsent sein auf Social Media und auf
den Plätzen doch wie viele Menschen sie
damit auch erreichen muss ich
zeigen nach Plagiatsvorwürfen gegen AFD
Chefin Alis Weidel wegen ihrer
Doktorarbeit sieht die Universität
beayut nicht genügend Hinweise für eine
weitere Prüfung die Arbeitweise zwar
Zitierfehler auf dennoch reichten diese
Passagen nicht aus um ein
grobfahrlässiges oder absichtliches
wissenschaftliches Fehlverhalten zu
belegen berichtet die
Universität ein Schüler hat in einer
Schule nah Heidelberg eine Mitschülerin
getötet der 18-Jährige tatf tige konnte
inzwischen gefasst werden er war nach
der Tat geflüchtet die Schülerin starb
bereits am Ort des Geschehens alle
Versuche sie zu reanimieren blieben
erfolglos laut Polizei hatte sie den
Täter bereits im letzten Jahr wegen
körperlicher Gewalt
angezeigt schon jetzt ist die Rede von
der größten Umweltkatastrophe die
Dänemark je erlebt hat ein riesiger
Hügel mit giftiger Erde der seit Jahren
auf einer Deponie gelagert wird ist ins
Rutschen geraten trotz aller Versuche
die gefährliche Masse aufzuhalten droht
sie in einen nahegelegenen Fluss und
dann ins Meer gespült zu werden die
Firma Nordic waste in der Nähe der
kinstadt raners hat jahrelang gut an der
giftmüllentsorgung verdient aber jetzt
angesichts des gewaltigen Schadens
Insolvenz angemeldet so hat kaldi
berichtet
unaufhaltsam bisher jeden Tag ein paar
Meter weiter rutscht der riesige Haufen
hochkontaminierter Erde auf das örtchenö
und den kleinen flussing zu bedroht
Mensch und Natur die Fjorde und das Meer
die Ministerpräsidentin dieser Tage vor
Ort spricht von der wahrscheinlich
größten Umweltkatastrophe
Dänemarks in erster Linie geht es um den
Schutz der Umwelt und der umliegenden
Gemeinden und dann müssen wir den
Verursacher zur Kasse
bitten in einer ehemaligen leengru
sammelte das Unternehmen n Stoffe von
überall her aus Verbrennungsanlagen
Ölplattform Tankstellen wer für den
Erdrutsch aufkommen muss darüber wird
nun gestritten hinter Nordic WS steht
der Milliardär Torben östergart Nielsen
sein Unternehmen meldete Insolvenz an
die Regierung wirft ihm Flucht aus der
Verantwortung vor wenn du sehr stark
bist und man muss sagen dass Dänemarks
sechsreichster mann das ist dann hast du
auch eine Verantwortung sehr gut zu sein
und das vermissen wir in diesem
Fall nehmen das auf die Reinigung
kontaminierter Erde spezialisiert ist
weist jede Verantwortung zurück starke
Regenfälle sein für die Erdrutsche und
die Naturkatastrophe Verantwort aber
auch die Gemeinde steht in der
Kritik sie hat die Genehmigung ohne
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung erteilt
ich wage also zu behaupten dass in
diesem Fall beide verantwortlich
sind die Aufräumarbeiten und die
Sicherung des Gewässers könnten Jahre
dauern Fachleute und bis zu 300
Millionen Euro
verschlingen es sind Bilder einer
aufsehenerregenden weiten Reise Japans
weltraumsonde Slim hat erste Daten und
Fotos von der Landung auf dem Mond
geschickt darauf unter anderem zu sehen
das gelbe Raumfahrzeug auf der felsigen
Mondoberfläche es sei weich gelandet nur
55 m vom Zielpunkt entfernt so die
japanische
Weltraumbehörde die Forschenden sind
zufrieden trotz eines Missgeschicks
steht offenbar auf dem Kopf und seine
Solarzellen können derzeit kein Strom
erzeugen und jetzt komen wir zur
Handball EM n Deutschland steht ja im
Halbfinale trotz den die Nagel gestern
gegen Ken ja das letzte Hauptrundenspiel
war echt zum Abhaken ein Festival an
Fehlwürfen personelle Experimente in
Halbzeit 2 die wenig Stabilität brachten
egal jetzt heißt es volle Konzentration
auf morgenabend und auf den Gegner
Weltmeister
Dänemark die Belohnung gab dennch einen
Döner als mit nachtnack zum
selbstbelegen trotz schwacher Leistung
und klarer 24 Z 30 Niederlage gegen
Kroatien allein 24 Fehlwürfe dienen hier
als negativer Beleg sei drum das große
Ziel Halbfinale ist erreicht die
ersehnte Medaille zum Greifen nah ganz
ehrlich glaube es gibt keine bessere
Situation dass du ein Halbfinale zu
Hause hast vor eigener vor eigenem
Publikum in diese Arena und trotzdem
hast du nicht den Druck am Mittag auf
der offiziellen Pressekonferenz eine er
Begegnung zwischen beiden Halbfinalisten
ganz so herzlich wird es morgen beim
Duell ums Finale sicher nicht
zugehen ja und beide Halbfinals morgen
live bei uns im ZDF ab 17:35 Uhr erst
Frankreich gegen Schweden und dann
Deutschland gegen Dänemark zur
Fußballbundesliga da hat Bayern München
gestern Abend das Nachholspiel gegen
Union Berlin knapp und glanzlos gewonnen
durch das 1:0 von Rafael Guerrero in der
46 Minute Bayern jetzt wieder mit vier
Punkten Abstand auf Tabellenführer
Leverkusen zweiter überschattet wurde
das Spiel durch das unsportliche
Verhalten von unionrainer nenard
biadesta gegenüber Bayernstürmer Leroy
sané dafür erhielt er vom Schiedsrichter
die rote Karte und wurde heute vom DFB
für drei Spiele gesperrt plus 25 000 €
Geldstrafe nach dem Erfolg in kitzbül
wieder ein spektakulärer Sieg von Lin
ste Deutschlands lanum as gewann gestern
Abend den Weltcup von schlattming der
Münchner setzte sich im Flutlichtrennen
bei zum Teil strömenden Regen gegen den
Norweger Timon augan und den Franzosen
Clement Noel
durch Strasser übgens Samstag bei uns
Gast im Aktuellen Sportstudio danke und
jetzt noch eine weltweite Sensation ein
jahrhundertpfund heißt es heute aus
Österreich ein langverschollenes Werk
von Gustav Klimt ist wieder aufgetaucht
und kommt unter den Hammer das Fräulein
Lisa farbenprächtig und nahe zuu
markelos hat das Gemälde mehr als 100
Jahre überstanden es hing wohl in einer
Villa bei Wien die Fachwelt kannte das
Bild nur durch eine matte schwarz-weiß
Aufnahme am 24 April soll das Fräulein
Lisa in Bund versteigert werden
Schätzwert 30 bis 50 Millionen
Euro viel Wind und kräftiger Regen wird
für morgen erwartet mehr dazuleich im
Wetter von ötin terle
das heute journal können Sie um 21:45
Uhr sehen mit Christian siebas und diese
Nachrichtensendung läuft morgen nicht
wie gewohnt um 19 Uhr sondern nach Ende
des ersten Handball EM Halbfinales das
heißt gegen 19:20 Uhr Morgen begrüßt sie
dann Barbara hallweg auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Regen in der
kommenden Nacht ist hauptsächlich dieser
Warmfront hier geschuldet aber sie sehen
da nähert sich schon diese Kaltfront und
die bringt deutlich mehr Regen und viel
mehr Wind ja und dahinter lockert es auf
in der Nacht also viele Wolken und Regen
mit der Warmfront im Nordwesten da
regnet es dann mehr der Wind legt
außerdem zu das liegt an der
herannahenden Kaltfront zwei
Temperaturen von 0 bis 9° ganz im Westen
Deutschlands und morgen ist viel los
beim Wetter die Kaltfront schwenkt
einmal von Nordwest nach Südost und
dabei gibt es kräftige Schauer ja und
der Wind der liegt legt ordentlich zu
und erreicht in der norddeutschen
Tiefebene 60 bis 90 km pro Stunde und
bis 110 km pro Stunde an der Nordsee und
das bei höchsten Temperaturen von 7 bis
13° maximal die nächsten Tage komplett
ruhiges Wetter mit viel Sonnenschein 3
bis 9° am Samstag 4 bis 13° dann am
Montag und damit einen schönen Abend